From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Georgette Dorn: Good afternoon,
my name is Georgette Dorn
and I'm the chief of
the Hispanic Division.
It's a great pleasure to welcome
Professor Egginton to the Library
of Congress and this
wonderful, wonderful crowd.
Please close all your
electronic devices,
so we can hear the
speaker very well.
And I want to thank the
Poetry and Literature Center
for cosponsoring this event,
especially Rob Casper is
director and Anya Creightney.
And of course, Talia Guzman-Gonzalez
who organized this event
and is Talia who will
introduce our speaker.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzalez:
Good afternoon,
my name is Talia Guzman-Gonzalez
and I'm a reference librarian
and [inaudible] specialist
in the Hispanic Division.
I would like to welcome you
all to the Library of Congress,
your library as I'd like to say.
Before I introduce our
distinguished speaker,
I would like to thank
the good people of Poetry
and Literature Center, the
director, Robert Casper,
and the program specialist,
Anya Creightney, and the intern
for helping us with
the co-sponsorship
and setting up the room.
My colleagues in the Hispanic
Division, especially Catalina Gomez
and our Chief Georgette Dorn.
Also deserve a big thank you for
their support and help in sorting
out all the details for
making this event possible.
Today we have the honor to
welcome Professor William Egginton
for what I'm sure will
be a fascinating lecture
on Miguel de Cervantes
Saavedra and the art of fiction.
This talk is the third
and last in a series
of events celebrating the
life and work of Cervantes
in the 400th year of his death.
In case you missed any
of our previous events you can
visit our webpage for the webcast
and those events and many other
great talks that we organize
in the Hispanic Division.
Professor Egginton is the Andrew W.
Mellon professor in the humanities
and chair of the Department of
German and Romance Languages
and Literatures at Johns Hopkins
University where he teaches Spanish
and Latin American literature,
literary theory, and the relation
between literature and philosophy.
He's also the director
of the Alexander Grass
Humanities Institute at Hopkins.
Professor Egginton's body
of work is a testament
to the erudition of a true scholar.
His breath and depth of research
demonstrates originality,
theoretical strength and passion.
He is the author of How the
World Became a Stage, Presence,
Theatricality and the Question
of Modernity which is based
on his dissertation at Stanford
university under the direction
of Hans Ulrich Gumbrecht.
And Perversity and Ethics,
A Wrinkle in History,
The Philosopher's Desire.
The Theater of Truth and In
Defense of Religious Moderation.
He's also the coeditor
with Mike Sandbothe
of the Pragmatic Turn in Philosophy.
The Translator of Lisa
Block de Behar,
The Passion of an Endless Quotation.
And the coeditor with David E.
Johnson of Thinking with Borges.
And I want to take this opportunity
that he's also the author
of several Borges books and articles
that we're going to have a talk
with Maria Kodama next
week on Wednesday at 6:30.
He's also the author of numerous
articles and book chapters
and the contributor for the New
York Times online forum The Stone
which his fascinating.
And he has written on topics ranging
from neuroscience, law and zombies,
there's a great title there.
He's here today to talk
about his most recent work,
The Man Who Invented
Fiction, How Cervantes Ushered
in the Modern World
published in 2016,
an indication that some good
things did happen in 2016 for sure.
Please join me in welcoming
Dr. William Egginton.
[ Applause ]
>> William Egginton: Thank you
Georgette, thank you Talia,
and all the colleagues at the
Library of Congress, it's an honor
and a real pleasure to be here.
I've visited our library before,
but never in this capacity
and it's a real honor as I say.
One brief note just because it's
so hot off the press David Castillo
and I just published our book
Medialogies, Reading Reality
in the Age of Inflationary
Media, which had the distinction,
it came out two weeks
as someone pointed
out on Twitter soon
thereafter of having --
we started writing it
three or four years ago.
All of our political examples
were in fact about Donald Trump
with no knowledge even
that he was going
to declare himself as a candidate.
So, it's an analysis of
media practices in the 20th
and 21st century from the framework
of media revolutions 400 years ago.
So, the idea that the grounds
were laid for this kind
of political turmoil 400 years
ago is an interesting one
and certainly thought-provoking.
So, what I plan to do today, is the
sound good for everyone in the room?
>> Yes.
>> William Egginton: Yeah?
Is a reading from the
Man Who Invented Fiction.
It'll probably be 45 or 50 minutes,
I'll jump around a little bit here
and there in the book and
accompany it with some images,
some of them are in the
book, others supplemented.
Most of the images
if not all have come
from The George Peabody Library,
our Collection of Rare Books
at Baltimore which I decided
to focus on in my research.
We have such great
collections from 17th
and 16th century Spanish literature
that I thought this was a resource
that really needed to be
brought to the public eye.
So, without further
ado I'll get into it.
Something strange happened
in the winter of 1605,
at the heart of the world's
most powerful empire in a time
of economic decline and political
stagnation word started spreading
about of all things a book.
The dealers quickly sold out,
those who could read passed
increasingly threadbare copies
from hand to hand, and those who
could not read began to congregate
in inns, village squares and taverns
to hear those pages read aloud.
Packed in tightly around worn
wooden tables, clutching goblets
of acrid wine and warmed by a smoky
hearth those fortunate enough to be
in attendance when a literate
benefactor declaimed the opening
words were not treated to an
epic rendering of heroic deeds,
a lyrical [inaudible]
to a shepherd's love
or a pious reflection on the
martyrdom of a beloved saint.
Instead, as they washed back
their dregs and squeezed in closer
to get a better seat
they were among the first
to hear these now immortal
opening words.
Somewhere in La Mancha in a
place whose name I do not care
to remember a gentleman
lived not long ago.
It would not be long in fact,
until the tipsy crowd was cackling
in delight over the misadventures
of what would become world
literature's most recognizable
protagonist, a rickety geriatric
member of the lower gentry
who foolish enough to have traded in
much of his land for countless books
of chivalry quote became
so caught up in reading
that he spent his nights
reading from dusk till dawn
and his days reading
from sunrise to sunset.
And so, with too little sleep and
too much reading his brains dried
up causing him to lose his mind.
In this state, the pitiful
gentleman has quoting again,
the strangest thought any
lunatic in the world ever had,
which was that it seemed
reasonable and necessary for him,
both for the sake of his honor
as a service to the nation
to become a knight errant and
travel the world with his armor
and his horse to seek adventures and
engage in everything he had heard
that knight errants engage in.
Writing all manners of wrong
and by seizing the opportunity
and placing himself in danger
and writing those wrongs
winning eternal renown
and everlasting fame end quote.
How they howled with
laughter as they heard
for the first time the exploits
of this ridiculous geezer wandering
a countryside they recognize
as their own and coming
face-to-face with the kinds
of people they spent
their days with,
the kinds of people they
were likely rubbing shoulders
with as they listened to this tale.
Mule drivers and scullery
maids, farmers
and prostitutes, barbers
and innkeepers.
For the first half hour,
our tavern crowd is treated
to the circus it came for.
The aging madman mistakes
a [inaudible] for a castle,
its owner for a noble knight and two
common wenches for exquisite ladies.
He requests the boon of an official
dubbing from the wily innkeeper
who knows his tales of chivalry
enough to keep in character,
even as the hapless hero
wreaks havoc on his guests
and provokes giggles in
the ladies of easy virtue.
As he chastises a farmer
and he chastises a farmer
for beating a servant, but then
trusts in his chivalry enough
to send them off together again
with a mere promise of recompense
to the farmer's like sly delight
and the servant's enduring agony.
The story our tavern
crowd is hearing
in other words is pure embodied
satire, an unbridled ribbing
of an impoverished and
degenerate gentry anesthetized
by the cliched literature
of a previous century.
Well into their second
or third round
of libations our tavern goers
hear how the aged gentleman comes
to realize he's missing
something and resolves quote,
to return to his house
and outfit himself
with everything, including a squire.
Thinking he would take on a neighbor
of his, a peasant who was poor
and had children, but
was very well-suited
to the chivalric occupation
of a squire.
At home for two weeks the delusional
knight convinces his peasant
neighbor to join him
promising him upon completion
of their quest an island,
which he insists on calling
in proper epic form by its
Latinate name an insular.
Insouciant to the geographically
inconvenient fact
that they are wandering
around the arid plains
of central Spain many days travel
from any significant body of water.
The introduction of this stout
simple neighbor changes everything.
For the listeners and the tavern and
for us they're literary descendants
until Don Quixote seeks
out Sancho Panza for these
of course are the characters
I've been describing.
He is but a foil, a rube, a
brilliantly crafted one to be sure,
but nonetheless an
object of derision
that our tavern fellows would
feel comfortable ridiculing.
At the time of the writing,
the mentally ill were protected
from prosecution from certain
crimes, but they were not protected
from abuse, marginalization and
being used as the butt of a joke
for a populist star
for entertainment.
Having found Sancho Panza though
Quixote suddenly becomes something
quite different.
Within a page or two of setting
off together the two companions
encounter their most
iconic adventure.
Good fortune is guiding our affairs
better than we could have desired
for you see here Sancho, 30 or more
enormous giants with whom I intend
to do battle and whose
lives I intend to take.
And with the spoils we
shall now begin to grow rich
for this is righteous warfare and it
is a great service to God to remove
so evil a breed from
the face of the earth.
What giants said Sancho Panza.
Those over there replied his
master with the long arms,
sometimes they're almost
two leagues long.
Look your grace Sancho
responded, those things that appear
over there aren't giants,
but windmills and what looks
like their arms are the sails
that are turned by the wind
to make the grindstone move.
Predictably, famously Don Quixote
does not heed his good squire's
commonsense admonitions, but instead
charges ahead spearing the enormous
sail of a windmill's arm with
his lance being lifted horse
and all off the ground
and smashed back
down in a miserable aching heap.
Sancho's reaction to his mishap
though is different from those
that greeted all his
previous antics.
Where the others treated Quixote
as a spectacle, an entertainment
or a nuisance Sancho
responds with compassion.
Seeing his master lying
next to his fallen horse
and shattered lance Sancho quote,
hurried to help him as fast
as his donkey could carry him.
And when he reached them,
he discovered that Don Quixote
could not move because he had taken
so hard to fall on [inaudible].
God save me said Sancho,
didn't I tell your grace
to watch what you were that
these were nothing but windmills
and only somebody whose head was
full of them wouldn't know that.
From the limited outlook of his own
simplicity Sancho sees his master
fail, sees the calamitous
consequences of his delusions,
and yet decides to
accept him despite them.
Quoting again, it's in
God's hands said Sancho,
I believe everything
your grace says,
but sit a little straighter
it looks like you're tilting,
it must be the battering
that you took.
In the space of a few pages
what had started as an exercise
in comic ridicule and
as the narrator insists
on several occasions, a
satirical sendup of the tales
of chivalry has taken on an
entirely different dimension.
It has begun to transform itself
into the story of a relationship
between two characters
whose incompatible takes
on the world are bridged
by friendship,
loyalty, and eventually love.
When deep in the second part
published 10 years after the first,
a mischievous duchess
elicits Sancho's confession
that he does indeed know that
Quixote is mad and then accuses him
of being quote, more of
a madman and a dimwit
than his master for following him.
Sancho replies, if I were clever man
I would've left my master days ago,
but this is my fate and
this is my misfortune.
I can't help it.
I have to follow him, we're
from the same village,
I've eaten his bread,
I love him dearly.
He's a grateful man, he gave me his
donkeys and more than anything else,
I'm faithful so it's impossible for
anything to separate us except a man
with his pick and shovel.
As the great German Scholar
Eric Alba [phonetic] wrote
of Sancho's attachment to Quixote,
the former quote, learns from him
and refuses to part from him
and in Quixote's company he
becomes cleverer and better
than he was before, end quote.
The fire light flickering
across the faces
of our eager listeners registers
no [inaudible] cast by this change.
The raucous tavern crowd
continues to laugh as before.
But as the innkeeper shouts for last
call and starts to close up shop,
as the stragglers put down
their empty cups and make
for the door chattering about
the tale and making plans
to return the next evening so as not
to miss what happens next something
imperceptible to them has happened.
The crowd that arrived that first
evening was used to ridicule,
they were fluent in
the language of satire.
With Don Quixote they were
learning a new language,
today we call that language fiction.
Most of us if asked would
probably define fiction
as an untrue story we
read for entertainment
in full knowledge that
it's not true.
And certainly, that
much is accurate.
But think about what
actually happens to us
when our eyes start reading the
words on the page or the characters
in our favorite show start
to interact with one another.
In a memorable scene from F. Scott
Fitzgerald's the Great Gatsby,
Nick Caraway's mind drifts out of
the apartment where he's entangled
in some debauchery and imagines how
quote, high over the city our line
of yellow windows must have
contributed their share
of human secrecy to the casual
watcher in the darkening streets
and I saw him too looking
up and wondering.
I was within and without
simultaneously enchanted by
and repelled by the inexhaustible
variety of life, end quote.
Like Nick when we engage with
fiction we are both within
and without the story we
are reading or watching.
We are simultaneously ourselves
locked into our own particular view
on the world and someone else,
maybe even someone very different
from ourselves feeling how he
or she inhabits a very
different world from ours.
And like Nick, we can
on the pages of our book
or on the screen before our
eyes be simultaneously enchanted
and repelled by the
inexhaustible variety of life.
That ability to experience different
and at times even contradictory
realities without rejecting one
or the other is one of the
main reasons we are drawn
to fiction in all its forms.
About a half year before on
a hot August day in 1604,
a man walked through the
dusty streets of [inaudible],
Spain clutching in his
right hand a heavy package.
In the absence of any authentic
portraits we must trust his own
words to know that he was
brown haired and silver bearded
with an aquiline, but
well-proportioned he adds,
nose and cheerful eyes
partly hidden behind a pair
of smeared spectacles not shown in
this 19th century rendition here.
Resembling in the words of one
of his literary rivals
badly fried eggs.
Of medium build and missing most of
his teeth, which was common enough
in those times for a man
just shy of 60 years.
He had lost the use of his left hand
many years earlier when he was hit
by [inaudible] shot while
boarding a Turkish galleon
at the battle of [inaudible].
His clothes from the wide
rough collar around his neck
to the tight stockings
exposing the hardened muscles
of his calves would have broadcast
to his fellow pedestrians his status
as a member of the gentry.
Just as their ragged state would've
advertised his rather precarious
financial straits.
Even though only recently arrived,
the man would hardly have been
a stranger to his neighbors
in [inaudible] meatpacking quarter
[foreign language], where he
and his extended family occupied
the floor above a raucous tavern.
The [foreign language] was
on the outskirts of a town
that in 1604 could not keep pace
with its exploding population.
The rush of newcomers
driven by the transfer
of King Philip the third's court
from Madrid four years earlier
and brought new life and
glamor to [inaudible].
But it has also imposed
a severe housing crisis.
While the government tried to
control growth and crowding
by issuing zoning laws limiting the
city's brightly colored buildings
to two stories the city's
savvy landlords responded
by constructing houses with
hidden stories in the back.
Thus, this motley family
was not alone
in the landlord [inaudible] house,
all told there were some 20 tenants
living in its 13 rooms almost all
of them friends or relations
of Miguel de Cervantes.
As the aging soldier stepped
gingerly over the rivulets of blood
and awful that cut through
the district's packed dirt
and stone streets his
one good arm hugged
that heavy package
tightly to his chest.
In it were hundreds of sheets
of paper, each sheet packed
to the margins with a neat slanted
hand of a professional scribe.
Cervantes' own more round and
slightly meandering script
which would have overflowed
the many more hundreds of pages
of his blotted, scratched
and corrected manuscripts
can only be seen today
on a few precious remnants.
A signed document from his 1597
stay in in Seville's municipal jail
where his thought that he first
dreamt up Don Quixote and a letter
to the Archbishop of
[inaudible] shown here.
The very prologue whose words he
penned only days before both speaks
to his evident concern that he be
too closely associated with the book
and bears witness to the style of
writing that its pages initiated.
Though I seem to be the father
he tells his idle reader,
I'm the stepfather of Don Quixote.
And then he proceeds to inform
the reader that he won't beg him
to ignore or forgive the
book's faults because quote,
you have a soul in your body and a
will as free as anyone's and you are
in your own house where
you were Lord
as the sovereign is
master of his revenues.
And you know the old
saying, under the cover
of my cloak I can kill the king.
If the book seems to be to you
readers critical of society,
if it appears to you to
be saying the wrong kind
of thing Cervantes seems
to be telling his readers,
that's your responsibility.
You are free to judge not only the
book, but the world you live in,
free to resist, free revolt
against the values you've
been forced to believe in.
And most shockingly, in a prologue
approved under the royal seal
under the cloak of your
own thoughts you are free
to kill the king himself.
Cervantes is a valiant soldier and
a committed Christian had changed
over a lifetime of disappointments.
He had grown weary and wary
of his country's vaunted
certainty, cynical of its promises.
But while he could never openly
accuse the crown in Spanish society
of hypocrisy of deceit of
having abandoned all true values
and noble virtues in
exchange for a tissue
of false convictions
and scapegoated excuses.
He could and did write a book that
showed precisely these things.
Like so many around him Cervantes
had been pulled from Madrid
to [inaudible] with a transfer of
the royal court, hoping to benefit
in some small way from
the constant flurry
of economic opportunity created
by the monarchies granting
of favors and paid posts.
As he looked around him at the rush
to profit though he must've felt
the sardonic resignation of a man
who had himself too often
followed this very route,
only to be disappointed.
A student and intellectual he had
escaped his homeland as a young man
after wounding another man in a duel
and experienced firsthand
the Spanish state's violent
confrontations with Islam
and the Mediterranean.
Returning to Spain a decorated
hero he had been captured
by barbarous pirates and
held in squalid captivity
for five years during which time
he experienced both the depravities
and the humanity of
an enemy culture.
Ransomed at last he regained
a homeland that seemed
to have forgotten his
sacrifices and that was intent
on covering the patent failures
of its domestic and foreign policy
with a patchwork of religious
fanaticism and ethnic scapegoating.
Rebuffed and humiliated
repeatedly in his quest for reward
and recognition for his service the
aging warrior gradually turned back
to his first love, writing.
Eventually producing
Don Quixote along
with a treasure trove
of other great works.
Ironically, it seems his
unparalleled success was forged
by life of almost continuous
failure.
A century before Cervantes' birth
time still fresh in people's memory.
Spain was not even a nation
and kings were a little more
than local lords, psions of
landowning families with deep ties
to region language and local
population, the population
that tilled their lands and fed
them in exchange for promises
of protection from
neighboring powers.
In that time people knew
their place in the world.
It was written into their flesh
and spoken through their words
and gestures, clothes, and
habitats and the rituals
that mark their births,
marriages and deaths.
In the time since then
though a man's place
in the world had somehow
become more mobile.
New horizons opened up for
exploration and new possibilities
for attaining a higher
rung on the social ladder.
But with that change came questions
and uncertainties, who to become,
how to get there, how to survive.
Cervantes' own grandfather
had benefited
from that new mobility just
as his father had suffered
from the needs that it generated.
The former Juan de Cervantes
has been a well-regarded lawyer
from a family of cloth merchants
in [inaudible], city that while
under Christian domination since
the early 13th century had been the
capital of the Muslim
caliphate of [inaudible]
and had long exemplified Spain's
unique blend of Christian,
Muslim and Jewish cultures.
As a young man newly
married to the daughter
of a [inaudible] physician he took
a job as an assistant magistrate
in Alcala de Henares,
north of Cordoba
in the high plains of Castile.
This is a beautiful
16th-century painting of Alcala,
a view taken from outside
of its walls
and here is a contemporary
map hand-painted also
from the Peabody collection,
which I've centered Alcala.
It's hard to see from there, but
it's bigger and more important
at the time than Madrid
would have been.
Rodrigo, his second son,
and eventual father Miguel
was born there in 1509,
the same year that the Cardinal
Francisco Jimenez Cisneros founded
the city's university.
Alcala would become one of
Spain's greatest centers
of learning during the 16th
century, second only and renowned
to Salamanca and home of the first
complete multilingual printed Bible.
That Bible would henceforth be known
as the [inaudible] Bible in honor
of the Latin name for
Alcala [foreign language].
The University of Alcala
would later be moved to Madrid
where it is now the largest
university in Spain and one
of the largest in the
world [foreign language].
Rodrigo's attempt to support
his growing family as a surgeon
in a university town where as
Cervantes would later write quote,
of the 5,000 students
who studied that year
at the university 2,000 were
studying medicine clearly led
to not.
His money problems followed him
to [inaudible] where he tried
to insinuate himself into
a wealthier clientele
by padding the family's
lifestyle on borrowed funds.
In the summer of 1552, only a few
weeks before his daughter Magdalena
was born he was jailed for
failing to pay his debts
and his property was impounded.
It is during this stint in
debtors' prison that Rodrigo tried
to take advantages of the
inequities governing Spanish society
at the time by getting a court
to rule that he wasn't in fact
of noble lineage and not
subject to debtor laws.
At first, he was unable to
establish a legal basis for this
and the court dismissed his suit.
This initial failure to establish
his exempt status raised the
possibility that Cervantes' family
by and large, educated and literate
and dissenting as they did
from Cordovan merchants
had Jewish forebears.
Back in by [inaudible]
toward the end
of his own life Cervantes
cannot help but have reflected
on his father's failures there, the
lawsuits, the debts, the time spent
in prison whose forbidding walls
he must've passed with frequency.
He could also not have forgotten
his own scrapes with the law
and especially the
two months at least,
maybe more he spent among
the wretched inhabitants
of Seville's municipal jail.
Indeed, it may have been in its dark
cells that he dreamt up Don Quixote,
which as he tells us in his famous
preface was begotten in a prison
where every discomfort has its place
and every mournful
sound makes its home.
Now, almost 20 years
later, the pages he gripped
in his one good hand would complete
their journey from captivity
to freedom, from darkness
to light via the caustic wit
of an inveterate gambler,
adventurer, soldier and storyteller,
a man born on the threshold of a New
World who had learned the hard way
that freeing oneself from
history and tradition could lead
to other sorts of bondage.
As the criminalization of
Spanish urban society took route
over the second half of the
16th century it was accompanied
by the emergence of a
genre of literature devoted
to the social outcast
and criminal deviant.
What has been called the
literature of roguery
or the [foreign language]
reached its acme in Europe
at the end of the 16th century.
And in Spain with the
runaway success
of Mateo Aleman's novel
Guzman de Alfarache
which was published simultaneously
with the republication
of the famous anonymous book
that has been called the first
picaresque novel [foreign language].
[Foreign language] had
been published in 1554,
although the Spanish
literary historian,
Americo Castro dates its
composition to the 1530's.
But the censorship of
the inquisition ensured
that it would only be reprinted
once before the end of the century.
And in that reprinting, it was a
highly, highly abridged version.
Riding on the coattails of the
Guzman, however, the new edition
of [foreign language] was an
extraordinary success leading
to nine different editions
being in circulation by 1603.
Guzman has clearly tapped
into a real desire on the part
of Spanish readers to delve into
the world of the underclasses,
to experience it from the
perspective of one of its own.
Indeed, Aleman's book
immediately sparked imitators,
including a sequel by a [inaudible]
lawyer named Juan Martine
[phonetic], of which 14 editions
were printed before Mateo Aleman
could come out with his
own second part in 1604.
The picaresque as typified by the
Guzman and its followers centered
on a criminal life narrated
by the criminal himself.
The [inaudible] desires only
freedom and the satisfaction
of his basest desires
and he has no scruples
about how to achieve his goals.
When Guzman encounters a sympathetic
priest in Italy who takes him in
and tries to help him he repays
the good man by robbing him
and then loses all
the money gambling.
The fact that this genre
became so popular just
as urban criminality rose
to unprecedented levels
in Spanish society was responding
with an ever-increasing legal
and punitive bureaucracy
should not be a surprise.
Whereas, the inquisition
censored [inaudible]
such that the 1577
edition was printed
without its fourth
and fifth chapters.
Guzman, along with [inaudible]
and other highly successful
books made it
through the censors unscathed in
the early years of the 17th century.
It is clear that the
portrayal of a social outcast
and his parasitic perspective on
society serve the regime's purposes
in the kind of image it wanted
to project to the outside world.
This image was that of
religious, moral public being beset
by parasitic outsiders and whose
only protection was their loyalty
to the Spanish crown and its laws.
At the same time, the
reading public and members
of acceptable Spanish society
were titillated by the possibility
of entering into the
rogue's perspective
and having their own
prejudices about his evil
and sociopathic ways confirmed.
Sitting in a dank, stinking
cell in Seville choked
by the smoke oil lamps when
lit at all and surrounded by
and unwashed mass of society's
dregs Cervantes spent many months,
we don't know for sure but perhaps
up to a half of a year between 1597
and 98, savoring firsthand the
perspectives of rogues and outcasts.
Knowing the truth of his
own story, a hero abandoned
by his country forced to accept
whatever demeaning labor came his
way and then maligned,
libeled and imprisoned
for his efforts gave Cervantes a
different kind of understanding
of the lives of those who
occupy society's bottom floors.
And how they could contrast
with the image painted
of them by books and the stage.
He could see in them the
gamblers, tricksters,
and hopeful social climbers that
would populate his novels and tales,
each and every one of them either
battling against or profiting
from the inability of others to
see them for who they really were.
In this world, people lived or
died by the sword of illusion
and Cervantes from the depths
of his disillusion was seeing
that world clearly,
perhaps for the first time.
Don Quixote was published only a
few years after Guzman de Alfarache.
But in his 22nd chapter there is
a clear reference to Mateo Aleman,
the author of Guzman de
Alfarache to Alemon's success
in creating a whole new
genre of literature.
At the outset of that chapter Don
Quixote looks up to see quote,
coming toward him on the same road
he was traveling approximately 12
men on foot strung together
by their necks like beads
on a great iron chain and
all of them wearing manacles.
Asking or asked by Quixote what they
are Sancho replies, this is a chain
of galley slaves, people forced
by the king to go to the galleys.
What do you mean forced Quixote
shoots back, is it possible
that the king forces anybody.
When Sancho explains that they
have been condemned to the galleys
because of their crimes
Quixote concludes that quote,
because these people are
being taken by force and not
of their own free will
here it is fitting to put
into practice my profession to
right wrongs and come to the aid
and assistance of the
wretched, end quote.
Sancho quickly tries to clarify
that as they are being punished
for their crimes, it's not
exactly accurate to say
that the king is forcing
or doing wrong to them.
But Quixote ignores him and
proceeds upon receiving permission
from the guards to talk
to several of the men.
Each describes to him the crime of
greater or lesser severity that led
to his having been
condemned to the galleys.
The last one Quixote interrogates
is a certain Geneste Passamonte
who the guards tell the
knight is famous on account
of the book he has
written about his life.
When Quixote asks if the book
is finished Geneste replies,
how can it be finished if
my life isn't finished yet.
Having finished his interrogation
of the prisoners Quixote decides
that it is indeed his
duty to free them all.
But after he has attacked the guards
and released their charges
he is rewarded for his mercy
by being stoned by them before they
run off in different directions.
Thus, at the simplest level,
the episode would appear
to be sending a similar
message to that
of the Guzman or any
of its followers.
These are criminals, they
are different from you
and me don't feel pity on them.
And indeed, should Cervantes written
an episode in which prisoners
on the way to the galley
were shown as truly deserving
of their fate it would certainly
have fallen afoul to censors
and gotten Cervantes
himself in hot water.
What he did though
was far more astute,
by making the principal
prisoner an obvious stand-in
for the literary character Guzman
de Alfarache who himself ends
up being condemned to the galleys.
Cervantes is telling his reading
public, not that prisoners are evil
and deserve no pity, but that what
they think they know about prisoners
and outlaws is nothing but illusions
made up for their own entertainment.
The other prisoners who tell their
tales before being overshadowed
by Geneste are a hodgepodge of minor
sad characters, an old man serving
as a go-between who is
suspected of sorcery.
Another who had stolen some laundry.
One who failed to withstand
trial by ordeal.
Another who had sexual
relations with his relative.
But all of them convicted on
shady or suspect evidence.
Only the literary character,
only Geneste Passamonte
is an obvious villain
for only Cervantes
seems to be saying,
only a fiction would be
so obvious and guilty.
In Cervantes' tales when
scalawags and scullions turn
out to have been people of quality
these revelations undermine the very
idea of a rapacious but alien
underclass that was being spread
by the literature known
as the picaresque.
Rogues are the projections
of the fears and desires
of an established social order.
Criminality is not something
they do, it is stitched
in the very fabric of society up to
and including the highest echelons
of political and ecclesiastic power.
But Cervantes who emerged
from months of imprisonment
in 1598 was a changed man.
This was the man who had around that
time would start writing what would
soon be published as Don
Quixote, along with some
of the stories he would
later publish
in his collection of
exemplary novels.
Regardless of whether the
writing began in prison
or shortly thereafter the
experiences he accumulated
in prison had an enormous
impact on the period
of creativity that was to follow.
But those experiences influenced
him in other ways as well.
The Cervantes who emerged from
that prison no longer believed
in the idea that Spanish society
and its government had been
selling his entire life.
While he had encountered many
reasons to doubt the official story
over the course of the previous
20 years, having been thrown
into prison for doing his job for
his government was the last straw.
The Cervantes who would as
would be expected from a poet
of renowned published
an ode in honor
of Philip the Second upon
his death later that year.
Would no longer write the kind of
laudatory verse he had produced
for the death of Elisabeth of
Valois 30 years earlier or even
for the felicitous
Armada 10 years earlier.
The poem published for
Philip's death was a masterpiece
of critical irony depicting
not the greatness of Philip,
but a man pompously declaring
the greatness of Philip.
His speech then quickly seconded
by someone Cervantes described
as a bully who calls it true,
accuses all who would question it
as lying like dogs and then
furtively glances both ways before
slipping away.
It makes sense that
Cervantes while inspired
by Aleman's remarkable success
with the newly popular genre
of the picaresque would engage
that literature an entirely
different way from those around him.
Cervantes who had tried to live by
the rules and follow the ideology
of the Spanish state, who had
been disappointed and rebuffed
at every turn, who had spent five
years among the infidels and come
to know their ways, who would
learn the techniques of the theater
and use them to analyze how
humans buy into illusions
and work to keep them alive.
And who had now lived on
the other side of the law
and had experience for himself.
This Cervantes understood
that the picero [phonetic]
like every other category of his
or that his society promulgated
for understanding the world
was a farce, an invention,
an illusion whose purpose
was to ensure
that the crown subjects
kept buying into the myth
of their own superiority.
And that their dependence
and their dependence
on the state for their protection.
He couldn't say all of
this in so many words,
but he could use the tools
he handled best to try to get
that message across in legally
and politically viable ways.
And so, he made his stories
about the society's outcasts,
these stories in fact, about
the fictional framework
that made them outcasts
in the first place.
The man who walked the
streets of his nation's capital
on that hot August day knew that
he had written something good.
He also certainly understood
that it was something new,
which he tells us himself
in several places.
There is no way, however,
that either he
or anyone else could have predicted
what would happen in January
of the following year when the
press of Juan de la Cuesta,
a Madrid-based printer whom
Francisco de Robles hired
to produce the actual book
would release the first
of what would be countless editions
of the ingenious gentlemen
Don Quixote of La Mancha.
Within a few months of its original
publication Cervantes needed
to apply for a new license
to have the book distributed
throughout the Iberian Peninsula.
And Robles and de la Cuesta
began to work on a second edition
to be released that same summer.
Before that edition hit the
bookstores two pirated editions
appeared in London, along
with two others in Zaragoza.
Already by April Robles
was spending a good part
of his time preparing legal suits
against the purveyors
of pirated copies.
Within only a few months
stacks of copies were loaded
onto the galleons embarking
from Seville for the New World.
And by June of the same year
the book's protagonists,
the diluted Don Quixote
and his squat simple sidekick Sancho
Panza had become iconic figures.
Their effigies carried in
parades and imitators popping
up in celebrations both
royal and [inaudible].
Upon seeing a student doubled
up in raucous laughter one day
King Philip the Third was reported
to have said, that student
is either out of his mind
or he's reading the
story of Don Quixote.
Cervantes' newfound fame was not
limited to the Spanish world.
Spain's cultural influence
of the time was as widespread
as its political and
military presence.
And Spanish works were regularly
disseminated and translated
in England, France and Germany,
not to mention in the Netherlands
and Italy which were still
under Spanish control.
Brussels saw two editions
released by 1611, figures dressed
as Don Quixote and Sancho appeared
at a procession in
Heidelberg in 1613.
And in England, John Fletcher
and Francis Beaumont adapted one
of the novel's interpolated
stories into their play,
the [inaudible] Cone written
between 1608 and 1610.
In 1612, Thomas Shelton published
his enormously successful English
translation, The History
of the Valorous
and Witty Knight Don
Quixote of La Mancha.
And although, it has been lost sadly
William Shakespeare joined forces
with John Fletcher to write a play
called Cardenio that was inspired
by another famous episode
from the novel.
From its publication in
the early days of 1605
to the present Don Quixote has
become perhaps the most published
work of literature in history.
More than that, its
influence on the writers
that have followed
has been unparalleled.
In the words of the critic Harold
Bloom, Don Quixote is a novel
that quote, contains
within itself all the novels
that have followed
in its sublime wake.
When the Norwegian Nobel Institute
polled a hundred leading fiction
writers to name the single most
important work of literature
in history more than half
of them named Don Quixote.
No other author's work came close.
In 1997, Life Magazine declared
the book's publication one
of the hundred most important
events of the entire millennium.
If Cervantes' direct
influence on the history
of literature is unparalleled
his indirect influence
on intellectual history
is simply immeasurable.
His books were to be found on
the shelves of every intellectual
in early modern Europe and
many of the Americas as well.
In 19th century England a
critic could take great umbrage
at a fellow scholar's inadequate
translation of Don Quixote referring
or writing quote, what judgment I
formed of you and your abilities
as an editor of Don Quixote, that's
how it's pronounced in England
of course, may easily be guessed
by this first token
you gave me of them.
It was plain that your book
would prove perfectly useless
to all classes of readers and
even hurtful to all learners
of that tongue if you
were to be its corrector.
And the stories of Don and his
squire were packaged into all shapes
and sizes, including for
the youngest readers.
And I'm going to skip over a
few slides because I had to cut
out a few pages of my presentation.
So, this is one abridged and
adapted to youthful by Sir Mar --
this is the Sir Marvelous
crack joke.
This is an early, no late
19th century edition.
Let me show you some of the artwork
and the plates are really marvelous
here and the colors they're even
on the screen not even
close to what you see
if you hold the edition
in your hand.
This we presume is Quixote himself
with his lance at the ready buried
in his books at the
beginning of the novel.
While writers like Fielding
and Flaubert and philosophers
like Schelling and Hagel have put
down for posterity what they thought
of Cervantes, his indirect influence
on thinkers like Locke, Descartes,
Kant and countless others whose
ideas would lay the foundations
for how modern individuals
in societies understand
themselves was just as profound.
In 1787, and this is fitting that
in this building or the building
at least next-door we
would mention this.
Thomas Jefferson wrote to a
nephew about the Spanish language
that he should quote, bestow great
attention on this and endeavor
to acquire an accurate
knowledge of it.
Our future connection with Spain
and Spanish America will render
that language a valuable
acquisition.
Well he no doubt meant
his admonitions
about geopolitics Jefferson's
own interest in Spanish culture
in fact came from his
fascination with Don Quixote
which he had borrowed from John
Cabot in advance of a sea voyage
to France in 1784 and used
alongside a Spanish dictionary
to master the language
during his 19-day voyage.
This was noted by John Quincy
Adams in a journal entry he jotted
down after a dinner
with Jefferson in 1804.
Although Adams then adds
a little note quote,
but Mr. Jefferson tells
large stories.
What is undeniable though is
the importance Jefferson placed
on the novel of which
he owned several copies
that one can still see at Monticello
in which he mentions dozens of times
in his letters over the years.
What took hold of his imagination,
like it did with that of so many men
and women was that central
idea of reality's pliability
in the face of political interests.
As he wrote in a pensive
letter to Edmund Randolph,
who would've conceived in 1789
that within 10 years we should have
to combat such windmills, end quote.
Jefferson's comment as superficial
as it seems nevertheless
leaves us a clue
as to why Cervantes' invention
had the impact it did.
With the publication of Don Quixote
Cervantes had managed at once
to encapsulate a problem that had
been encroaching on Western culture
for some time and to
offer a way forward.
The problem was that of how to
freely exercise the imagination
in a culture that strictly
controlled such expressions
by dictating the norms of truth.
The solution was the creation
of a new form of writing
that exempted itself from the
narrowest conception of truth
at the same time as it
revealed an even greater truth.
That reality itself was subject
to political distortions and that
to change the world one had to
reveal these for what they were.
In 1995, UNESCO declared April 23rd,
the international day of the book,
at least partly in recognition
of the almost simultaneous deaths
in 1616 of two of the
greatest writers of all time.
That the deaths of
William Shakespeare
and Miguel Cervantes
neither coincided,
the former died some 10 days later,
but England at the time had not
yet adopted the Gregorian
calendar we use today,
nor actually fell on April 23rd.
Cervantes probably died the
previous day and was buried
on that date later
etched into posterity.
Bestows on that date
a fitting irony.
The date of the book celebrates
those who write fiction.
The glorious artifacts that
aren't, histories that didn't happen
and lies that revealed
truths papered
over by the habits of everyday life.
Both Cervantes and his greatest
character die quietly in their beds,
surrounded by their loved ones.
But whereas the night of the
mournful countenance admits defeat
and renounces fantasy for a death
of stalled virtue his author's
mighty imagination lived
on in ways no one could
have predicted
and that few even grasp today.
On April 18th, 1616, Cervantes
was given his last rites at home
in Madrid, surrounded by
his wife and his sisters,
although not his daughter Isabel.
A dedication to the Count of Lemos
he composed the next day begins
with the words quote, with my
foot already placed in the stirrup
and full of fear in the face of
death great Lord, I write this.
Yesterday, they gave
me extreme unction
and today I write these words.
Time is short, my anguish grows,
my hopes diminish and yet,
despite all this I
carry it on my life
with the desire I have
to keep living.
Desire against reality.
The theme that resonates throughout
his greatest creations comes
to the fore in his last
statement to the world.
Critics have made much of the fact
that Don Quixote renounces
his madness on his deathbed,
cursing the passion for the
books of chivalry that drove him
out of his sanity and embracing his
real name Alonso Quixano, the good.
They've insisted that
this ending along
with the Cervantes' apparent
protestations that his only purpose
in writing the book was to skewer
the romances of chivalry should put
to rest any suspicions that Don
Quixote can mean anything other
than that.
But these critics it seems to
me failed to get his last joke.
It is as if they really believed
that the only alternative
to this reduction of
the extraordinary wealth
of the world's first and greatest
work of modern fiction would be
to interpret it as
expressing the opposing thesis
that somehow we Cervantes'
readers then
and now should be emulating
the tales of chivalry.
But the meaning of Don Quixote
cannot be either Cervantes' distaste
for or his love of
the tales of chivalry.
Indeed, asking what
Don Quixote means as if
such a shorthand answer could
ever be given already misses the
boat entirely.
If we really want to know let us
attend the deathbed scene our author
composed only a year
or so before his own.
Approaching their village
in the twilight hours
of their adventure
together the heroes pause
on a hillside overlooking
their home.
When he saw it, Sancho
dropped to his knees and said,
open your eyes my beloved country
and see that your son, Sancho Panza,
has come back to you if not very
rich, at least well flogged.
Open your arms and receive
as well your son Don Quixote
who though he returns conquered
by another returns the
conqueror of himself.
And as he has told me, that is the
greatest conquest anyone can desire.
To conquer oneself, to rein in
the force of desire the pull
of illusion this more
than the imminence
of death is what Quixote fears and
foresees crying, [foreign language]
as he enters the village
for passing two boys
in the street he overhears
their patter
and he misinterprets the sentence,
you won't see it in all the days
of your life as referring to
the imaginary lady Dulcinea.
As he has learned to do, Sancho
hastens to reassure his friend.
Strangely though this time his
down to earth realism in the face
of Quixote's superstitions
is intended
to save his illusions
not to dispel them.
He gathers from under his donkey
the terrified hair whose flight
from a pack of dogs
Don Quixote first took
as an evil omen, a
[foreign language].
And carefully hands this shuttering,
shaking hair to his master saying,
your grace is a puzzle let's suppose
that this hair is Dulcinea El Toboso
and these greyhounds chasing
her are the wicked enchanters
who changed her into peasants.
She flees, I catch her and
turn her over to your grace
who holds her and cares for her.
What kind of sign is that, what
kind of evil omen can you find here?
How far we have come
since Sancho sought
to set a windmill battered
Quixote right in his saddle
and straighten his
interpretation of reality.
For Sancho over the course of
his journeys and travails imposed
on him has learned to love
not only Quixote, the man,
but also the world
Quixote's dreamed for himself.
If you follow the errant
knight out of a fool's wish
to govern an [foreign language],
his desire to shelter his
master's illusions at the twilight
of their adventure seems born of
wiser sentiments, almost noble.
A few days later, Alonso
Quixano having fallen ill and now
under the loving care of his niece
and housekeeper loudly declares
that he is cured of his illusions,
renounces the tales of chivalry
and calls for a confessor and
a scribe to take down his will.
Immediately those around him,
especially his friend Sanson
Carrasco and Sancho Panza begin
to protest that he's wrong and
how can he say such things.
Quote, when we have news of the
disenchantment of lady Dulcinea
and now that we're on the point
of becoming like shepherds
and spending our lives in song
like princes now your grace
wishes to become a hermit.
For God sake, be quiet come to your
senses and tell us no more tales.
While the knight urges
reason, his companions know
that such realism is madness.
They realize that he is giving
up the essence of who he is
and has become even as reality
tightens its noose the urge
to be free reasserts itself.
The narrator, our supposed
ventriloquist of the Arab historian,
[inaudible] then tells us that the
news of his impending death quote,
put terrible pressure on the already
full eyes of his housekeeper,
his niece and his good squire Sancho
Panza forcing tears from their eyes
and a thousand deep sighs from
their bosoms because the truth is
as has already been said,
that whether Don Quixote
was simply Alonso Quixano
or whether he was Don Quixote of La
Mancha he had a gentle disposition,
was kind in his treatment of others,
and for that reason he was
dearly loved not only by those
in his household, but by
everyone who knew him.
Just as a character Don Quixote
had espoused and emulated the tales
of chivalry, another character
Alonso Quixano [inaudible] them
deciding that one is right
and the other wrong is exactly what
Cervantes' book doesn't allow us
to do.
For the space it opens,
the space of fiction is one
in which exactly those questions can
never be resolved because the space
of fiction does not refer
to the reality in question,
to the place where either
books of chivalry are evil
or they are harmless fun, the space
of fiction refers to that place
where such debates take place
and where we are called upon
to make a judgment about
them and about ourselves.
Whether Quixote was Quixano or
Quixano Quixote Cervantes seems
to be telling his present-day
interpreters he was still good one
way or the other.
And so, in a last joke
on his readers Cervantes has the
priest draw up a document stating
for posterity that quote, Alonso
Quixano the good commonly known
as Don Quixote had passed from
his life and died a natural death
and that he and only he could
ever be recognized as his author.
But of course, Cervantes didn't
name himself as that author,
but someone else, the fictional
historian [inaudible] whose
historical account has ostensibly
been the source of the book
and who's owed to his
own pen now ends it.
Here is the ode, for me alone was
Don Quixote born and I for him,
he knew how to act and I to write,
the two of us alone are one.
So, idol listeners as Cervantes
might say, if you really want
to believe that as the author
writes one last time quote,
my only desire has been to have
people reject and despise the false
and nonsensical books
of chivalry, end quote.
By all means be my guest after
all, it's [inaudible] who told you
so himself and he always
tells the truth.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you so much.
Professor Egginton will
take some questions.
But I want to remind you
also that [inaudible].
>> I read your book and
I liked it very much.
The fact that it started [inaudible]
to understand to the general reader.
And I also appreciated the fact
that [inaudible] not content centric
which focused more on Quixote itself
and just illuminated the cultural
like history [inaudible]
on the book,
so I thought that was
refreshing as well.
And my question to you
is have you ever thought
of the economic relationships in
the book and how it correlates
to [inaudible] in the book?
>> William Egginton:
Thank you and thank you
for the nice comments on the book.
I mean to a certain extent as
you know since you've read it,
I try and balance this analysis
of what fiction is and how came
about at this particular time with
this larger geopolitical history
of a kind of pivotal moment
in Western history not just
in Spanish history, but where the
Spanish Empire was also playing a
pivotal role.
And of course, that role is
economical to a certain extent.
I mean we talk about discussing
the book, the question of inflation
for example that racks the
Spanish economy leading to maybe
over the course of
Philip and his son
and his grandson six
bankruptcies of the Spanish crown.
And these clearly had a direct
impact on Cervantes' life,
the question of debt is
constant in Cervantes' writing.
As you know, gambling is
obviously an economic issue as well
and Cervantes was as
I say in one point
of this reading today
an inveterate gambler.
And he writes he shows enormous
knowledge about the gambling world
and the skills that the
cardplayers in particular need.
And so, he played a lot in
prison surrounded by people there
for economic crimes as well and
he was a tax collector for a time
in his life and a requisition
for the Armada.
So, he was deeply embedded
in this massive blooming early
modern imperial economy with all
of its incredible ups and downs.
Thanks for the question.
>> I appreciated how
much you pointed
out that Don Quixote was clearly
influential [inaudible] the western
world and that it reflects
Spain at that time
and it's a very [inaudible] book.
But I'm going to just look at
one particular aspect of it.
You said at the beginning Don
Quixote [inaudible] person,
also a geezer.
Okay, I was wondering
what is the perception
of Don Quixote being depicted that
way and by [inaudible] for example,
Native America example
where I don't think
such a character would
be part of their culture.
>> William Egginton: Yeah, no
it's quite possible and in fact,
our reception -- if you think about,
if you kind of reconstruct the
history and the age Quixote much
like Cervantes at the time that
he's writing Quixote would have been
from our perspective
a middle-aged man.
But the period if you've
made it to your late 50's
or early 60's you're
an outlier at the time.
As Cervantes talks about in his own
self-description, I've lost most
of my teeth, but you know
hey so has everyone else.
He was known as the [foreign
language], so he was a cripple.
In many ways he himself was, in
some ways I should say a model
for the kind of physical appearance
that he describes for Quixote,
but then he exaggerates it right.
He elongates Quixote, he makes
Sancho squatter, he intensifies,
enhances this representation
in certain ways.
So, I'm not sure that it had
any in its many translations
into the eastern world towards the
end of the century that this was
in any way looked upon as
different or particularly adverse
as a representation
of the character.
>> Yeah, just a quick,
a very quick question.
I haven't had the privilege
yet of reading your book,
but I was wondering did Miguel de
Cervantes did he become wealthy
from publishing this book?
>> William Egginton: No.
>> And his stature within the
society was it raised at all?
>> William Egginton: It
was, his stature was raised
to a certain extent,
but not to the extent
that he would've wanted it to be.
And this is something I do go
into quite some depth in the book
because it's a fascinating story.
You know the literary world, in
particular in Madrid, but in Seville
as well he frequented
both literary worlds.
This was very cutthroat.
He knew everybody and
everybody knew him.
So, you were all, you were
writing for a broader public,
but you were also writing for
your peers, the other playwrights.
That was his first attempt
was to become a playwright.
A poet was considered
kind of the highest level
and then the playwrights
because they were poets also.
And then what he was doing this
strange hodgepodge of prose
and throwing some poems in there
and occasionally this was, you know,
he was clearly a scraper in a way.
And comedy was considered
sort of the lowest form.
So, his books were
extraordinarily successful,
but you know he would sell the
rights for 1,500 reales which was,
you know, a couple months'
rent or something like that.
And then before you knew it he was
back borrowing money to live again.
And he was constantly making
reference in his prologue
as he was trying, the way that he
figured he could get by is finally
to get a sponsorship
essentially from a great lord.
And he did fine one [inaudible],
but it was in a sense too late.
That selling his wit in
his prologues was the way
that he was going to
finally make it, get by.
But he was always making
fun of his own poverty.
Well, there's a great -- let
just give you an exact example
because in the preface to the second
volume which he rushed to press,
not in the preface excuse me, I take
it back, in the censor's approval,
the approbation given
by the official censor.
The censor ostensibly is
telling a story about Cervantes
in which the censor says I
was working, I had this book.
Now censors don't usually
go into these long stories,
but suddenly this censor
starts telling this story
and his approbation.
I have this book on my desk because
I was working on censoring it.
And these French dignitaries came
to visit and one of them said,
oh are you working on a book
by Miguel de Cervantes
tell us about him.
What is his station, how is he
doing and I was forced to answer?
Well his station is quite
low, he's quite poor
and he's always complaining
about his lack of funds.
Now what we've pretty much
established that Cervantes
at this point knew the censors
as a literary community so well
that he actually wrote this
under the censor's name
and then had him slide it in.
So, he's always finding a way to
point out that look I should be,
I'm world-famous at
this point right.
That they know me in China as
he says in one of his prefaces.
They're asking me to come
and form a school in China.
I told the Emperor of China
how much are you going to pay
because I can only
come if you're going
to really give me some money for it.
So, he's always making this point.
>> Don Quixote is the first modern
novel, but also it has as air
of postmodernism [inaudible],
kind of metafictional attitude
to greatness [inaudible].
And most general a quite skeptical
view of the established view
of things and an objective truth,
putting objective truth
itself into question.
I mean, what is real, what is not
and the deceptiveness
of [inaudible] itself.
>> William Egginton: So that's
in some ways one of my points is
that what we have sometimes been
taught to call postmodern is
in fact already there from the
beginnings of the genre itself.
It's already there in the very first
works of modern fiction everything
that we're calling postmodern play,
kind of encapsulating
representations
within representations
that make one unsure
about what reality once
[inaudible] it's all there,
it's all from the very
beginning yeah.
>> Thank you so much.
>> William Egginton:
Thank you, my pleasure.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.